the opening scene features a 16-year-old
Max who is currently at a psychiatrist's
office the boy has a strange condition
the people who see his face die on the
spot as a result he has covered his
whole face with a white bandage he
explains the matter to the psychiatrist
saying that his condition originated
from his birth at the time of his
delivery the doctors and nurses were a
struck by his facial appearance and
moments later they all died however this
is not a painful death but a happy and
pleasurable death is face is probably so
beautiful that it causes a surge in
hormones that immediately ends a
person's life due to this Max's parents
had to move to a more secluded town he
is also homeschooled to protect himself
and the other kids however his rare
ability makes him feel very lonely
because the only people who aren't
affected by this are his parents who
probably ironically think he looks like
a foot the psychiatrist does not believe
in his story so he asks the boy to
remove his sunglasses and bandage and as
soon as Max does so he passes away not
long after the police show up but they
can't just arrest the boy for revealing
his face as a result he is as usual
released without any trouble back at
home Max is visited by his only friend
Dan while having their lunch together
Max's parents ask Dan to sign up for
some dating apps for Max so that he can
start going out rather than staying
inside the house every day dating apps
won't help with that dating apps are
crap later on Max asks his friend to hit
him with a brick and disfigure his face
which might disable his condition
however Dan claims that it won't be
effective reminding him of how they
tried that earlier with a hammer when
Max insists his friend punches him hard
on his face causing his nose to bleed
sensing Max's sadness Dan sets up a date
for him on Valentine's Day they meet a
girl named Erica at a restaurant but she
is clearly made uncomfortable by Max's
appearance in order to break the ice he
gives her a small gift a self-sown
handkerchief with her name on it he also
tries to compliment her and flirt with
her but the girl seems uninterested a
short while later they are interrupted
by Erica's ex-boyfriend Greg who appears
to be a tough intimidating and
aggressive man Alpha Greg he begins to
make fun of Max's appearance and even
assaults him physically with no apparent
reason despite being humiliated in front
of everyone Max tries to meet Erica some
other day but she refuses and walks away
because of all this Max suffers a mental
breakdown he walks up to a bridge with
the intention of throwing himself off
but before he can take such a drastic
step he is approached by a girl named to
Alex she surprisingly suggests that he
should go to a higher bridge if he
really wants to die Max angrily shouts
at her for offering such advice to
someone in such a dire state in response
Alex calmly says that she knew he
wouldn't jump as they Converse Max opens
up about his problems and expresses his
wish to live a normal life upon sensing
his depression Alex takes him to a
retirement home where she volunteers
there she introduces him to her elderly
friends Esther who battles Alzheimer's
disease and rosemary who has a terminal
illness they spend the entire day
conversing with them which cheers Max up
because he realizes that Esther's life
is more crap than his before they part
ways he asks Alex if they can meet again
sadly she turns him down and leaves the
next day max confides in Dan about Alex
and expresses his longing to see her
again hearing this Dan suggests that he
go to the same spot where they first met
and wait for her there heeding his
friend's advice Max sets out and waits
for her in a bus stop near the bridge
fortunately he sees her again and
convinces her to spend spend more time
with him see if a girl turns you down
just stalk her following this the duo
heads to a store where they buy a lot of
candy in order to fulfill one of Max's
dreams of swimming in them they then
fill his bathtub with candies and sit in
it from this point onwards the two start
bonding because if they can do something
that cringe together they can do
anything Max then shares his rare
condition with her but she doesn't seem
to be affected unlike others in turn
Alex also reveals about her rare
cardiovascular disease in which her
heart enlarged es whenever she shows or
feels any emotions any emotions she also
shows him how she is wearing a device
that monitors her heart every time but
since her condition is currently stable
she says that there's nothing to worry
about for Max is boring and makes her
feel nothing as days pass they start
growing closer and really seem to enjoy
each other's company one day they go to
a cinema Hall where they enjoy a movie
while also getting turboed later that
night Alex walks Max home and he invites
her inside while in his room he asks her
about the light bub on her jacket Alex
explains it's a dangerous indicator that
lights up when her condition worsens
amidst their conversation Alex removes
his sunglasses and looks into his eyes
Max is scared that she'll die but
surprisingly nothing happens probably
one has to see his full face to end up
in such a fate just then Max's parents
return home and are elated to see their
son finally having a girl over at a boy
son give her a spank H dear please they
also introduce an exchange student named
yiin who will be staying with them until
she finishes her studies they tell Max
to befriend her but he doesn't appear
interested in doing so the following day
max Alex Dan and his girlfriend plan a
Forest camping trip Max's mother asks
them to take yiin as well the boy is
hesitant about it but upon continuous
insisting he agrees later as they walk
in the woods Alex gets a minor injury
she scratches herself with a branch
seeing this Max tears a piece of his
face bandage and wraps it around her
wound his action makes her feel loved
which actually isn't good for her heart
as night falls they all set up a bonfire
and Camp during this time Alex expresses
her wish to see Max's face so he takes
her under the blanket covers her eyes
with the bandage and allows her to feel
his face the moment turns romantic even
though it's weird as and they end
up sharing a kiss in the next scene Max
and Alex visit the retirement home only
to learn that Rosemary is in a critical
phase of her life seeing the old lady
suffering a lot Alex is unable to hold
in her tears which is again bad for her
health as a result she walks out of the
room followed by Max Alex then reveals
that Rosemary is suffering a lot and the
nursing home is trying their best to
save her by putting her on several
medical devices which torture her even
more due to this she requests him to
take off his face bandage and show his
face to Rosemary in this way the old
woman will not have to suffer so much
and can die peacefully please Max mercy
kill this old lady for me with your face
Max is initially hesitant but after
thinking it through he agrees trauma or
no trauma he then goes to the ward room
and Reveals His Face letting her die
happily time passes and the relationship
between Max and Alex gets deeper and
deeper however things eventually begin
to change as Alex stops replying to his
texts and phone calls after a few days a
concerned Max decides to go to her place
once there he learns that the doctor has
doubled her medication dose because her
heart is getting larger hearing this Max
blames himself because they were meeting
a lot he asks if he can do anything for
her to which she asks him to take her to
a Party obliging Max takes her to a
party where Dan is also present with his
new girlfriend at first the atmosphere
is Lively as they dance and Savor the
moment soon after the song changes to a
romantic one prompting them to start a
romantic dance this causes Alex's heart
to beat very fast which makes her feel
uneasy when she starts bleeding from her
nose she excuses herself and rushes to
the bathroom now that Max is alone Dan
and his girlfriend join him for company
after a while they are approached by by
Erica's ex-boyfriend Alpha Greg and his
boys once more the aggressive guy
bullies Max and even goes as far as
removing his face mask Dan's girlfriend
happens to see his face which leads to a
tragic demise shortly after the police
arrive at the scene and arrest Max while
walking towards the police car max
notices Alex being transported to the
ambulance as her health seems to have
deteriorated badly damn who cares about
Dan's girlfriend though after spending a
day in prison Max is somehow bailed out
and he rushes to the hospital to see his
lover there he learns that Alex was
always going to die the medications she
took were only to suppress her emotions
but since she started to fall for him
she was willingly risking her life to
experience emotions due to which she
stopped taking the medicine now that she
is already on her final stage she makes
her last wish to see his face and die in
peace Max who can't let her go gets
enraged by this and claims that she
won't understand how it feels to see
someone die before him he refuses to
fulfill her request and storms out Max
returns home and tries to disfigure his
face with a brick just the usual however
his parents stop him and somehow managed
to calm him down with a comforting hug
at the same time yusin's cat enters the
room and sees his face this causes it to
die as well from this day onwards Max
who is upset by Alex's request stops
seeing her and does not even answer her
calls or texts one day max meets with
Dan and confides in him about everything
that has been happening in his life he
still doesn't care about killing his
girlfriend though he reveals about
Alex's critical condition and her
request hearing this Dan doesn't
understand why he is ignoring her
despite knowing that she is sick he asks
him to stay with her pointing out that
he might even lose the chance to bid her
goodbye his words seem to have the right
effect on Max and he eventually decides
to meet her the next day max goes to the
hospital and starts decorating Alex's
wardro with all of his Handcrafted
Creations he also apologizes for staying
away from her confessing that he wasn't
ready to face the possib ility of losing
her now that he understands her pain he
finally agrees to fulfill her earlier
request he then removes his face bandage
and lies down beside her before looking
at him she leans forward and shares a
romantic kiss she then opens her eyes
and looks at his face but it doesn't
actually kill her however it brings her
joy that has a negative impact on her
heart causing her condition to worsen
Max immediately summons the doctors who
managed to stabilize her for now he then
stays by her side throughout the night
until she ultimately succumbs to her
illness in the next scene we see the
devastated Max attending Alex's funeral
later on he goes to the same bridge
where he first met her he has an
envelope in his hand with Alex's name
written on it he then puts her favorite
chocolate in it and throws it into the
river ah that was a perfectly good
chocolate a few days later Max's murder
charges are dropped by the court as
forensic evidence proves that Dan's
girlfriend died a natural death
gradually recovering Max's Life starts
to take a positive turn and the terrible
feelings slowly Fade Away in order to
honor Alex he visits the retirement home
from time to time and spends time with
Esther eventually Max finds the right
way to use his unique ability he grants
euthanasia to those who request it so
they can look at his face and die
happily and peacefully this is so dark
the movie ends as Max narrates that the
most important thing he learned from
Alex is that his face isn't lethal to
those who love him unconditionally
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching